[Musique]
voilà Madame Chirac comme Claude m'a pas
donné de budget pour commander un vrai
sondage d'opinion je me suis permis de
réaliser un moi-même sur le personnel de
l'Élysée alors ne vous inquiétez pas
je dois vous prévenir
les résultats ne sont pas bons
les gens vous trouvent ringarde bonjour
la chatte bonjour
madame bonjour Madame Chirac
mystère ta carrière à égalité avec
Revest oui moi ça va j'ai compris mais
pas de panique nous allons faire en
sorte que les Français découvrent votre
vrai visage
va falloir apprendre à désobéir madame
Sirac
[Musique]
à partir de maintenant ça va filer droit
à l'Élysée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]